um it was 4th of July weekend and the
Beach Boys were playing at the Hollywood
Bowl and so everyone bought so it was
like everyone bought tickets that we
went and he played he was like rocking
out on everything was it's more of a
John stamus show than the beach boy show
at this point it is much more of a John
Stam show because the Beach Boys are
cadavers yes they're very yes literally
me most of them most of them the living
ones are cavers and then a lot of them
are literal cabers as well you want to
see when you go to see these Legacy
bands which I like doing because I love
classic rock here's my theory you want
the Rhythm Section to die first that's
why the who is still good to see live
cuz they got a younger drummer they got
a younger bass player and then everyone
else can do it all around them but you
need someone to hold down that beat you
need you need the drummer to go first
that that helps he's number one he's the
Marines of death for the band yeah you
put him in first to you send him on the
plane to Heaven first yes and then it
it's in succession by instruments to the
lead singer yes I don't know I guess
people go to see that new version of
Queen but why would what is that even
it's if it's if it's no Freddy Mercury
it's over it's done